mesdames et messieurs comme vous le
voyez je ne savais pas qu'il y avait un
spécialiste et couleurs juste devant moi
donc vous l'entendez je suis belge
d'origine flamande
mon nom est pete correct ce soir je vais
vous raconter mon histoire personnelle
pourquoi et comment je suis devenu un pc
un promoteur de co-création co-création
entre entrepreneurs sociaux et
investisseurs tous les deux réunis
autour d'un seul but
et c'est de créer et maximiser l'impact
sociétal positif mon histoire ma pré
histoire commence en 1928 à halle quand
mon grand père commence à vendre du vin
du chocolat et du café dans la
boulangerie de son père c'est le début
du groupe cover qui est maintenant un
des leaders de la grande distribution en
belgique
c'est toujours une entreprise familiale
mais ses côtés en bourse depuis 1977
comme vous l'entendez à bruxelles
ma vraie histoire commence à 2010
j'avais 40 ans crise de la quarantaine
et je me posais la question quel est mon
rôle dans cet ami donc il ya une
centaine d'actionnaires familial ses 27
mille employés et moi je me demande quel
est mon rôle
qu'est ce que je veux vraiment que les
mongols dans la famille dans ce groupe
qui suis vieux
mon père disait toujours qu'il ya quatre
types de personnalité dans notre famille
il ya les commerçants qui savent compter
mon grand père était vraiment un
commerçant il ya les ingénieurs qui
savent calculer mon père est vraiment un
ingénieux il ya les artistes qui ne
savent ni calculée ni côté mais qui
savent toucher et inspiré il y en a
quelques dans ma famille et quatrième
type ce sont les prêtres les soeurs dans
les générations précédentes
dans ma génération c'était plutôt des
philosophes et en 2010 je me demandais
moi c'est quel type
j'ai un diplôme de philosophie
d'ingénieurs d'architectes et même de
finances la question était simple qui
suis je
mais la réponse réponse je ne l'avais
pas en 2010
jusqu'au moment que j'ai reçu ce livre
c'est le représentant d'un show cas en
belgique qui m'a donné ce livre comment
changer le monde
ce livre a changé mon monde il y avait
un nouveau terme
entrepreneur social je ne connaissais
pas le livre est plein d'histoires
d'entrepreneurs sociaux 100% dédié pour
trouver des solutions au grand challenge
mondial
ce sont tous des entrepreneurs même s'il
y en a beaucoup qui choisissent de créer
une association sans but lucratif
il y en a d'autres qui choisissent de
faire un saut show business tous sont
des entrepreneurs réunis autour d'un
seul but c'est de crier et maximiser
l'impact sociétal positif donc
ce nouveau thème est-ce que je suis un
entrepreneur social
non je suis plutôt un investisseur et
c'est le deuxième thème inpact investing
bien aussi des états unis c'est un peu
la même philosophie c'est quelque chose
entre à gauche la philanthropie
classique et à droite le business as
usual pur et dur et inactivé sting est
créée en 2007 par la fondation
rockefeller qui accueillait ce thème et
c'est une réaction contre le modèle
américain de la philanthropie et des
grandes fondations comme militant jean
où on investit pour maximiser les
profits dans n'importe quoi et on donne
l'argent et on reçoit une attestation
fiscale
donc c'est inactive et sims aient
vraiment essayé de faire les deux
faibles du profit et faire du bien en
même temps j'ai vite découvert qu'il y
en a deux tendances dans cet espace il
ya le sochaux first et le fine ce feu et
moi je me demandais où j'ai découvert
que ma famille mon histoire était plutôt
à droite de cette ligne mais mon coeur
ce que je voulais vraiment faire c'est
plutôt à gauche de cette ligne est donc
pour résoudre ce problème à 2010 c'est
le dernier fait de cette allée
bouleversante 2010 j'écris mon propre
rôle mon propre holding et à cape town
impact capital investi dans des
entreprises sociales qui ont pour but ou
ou la mission sociale est primordiale et
l'aspect financier est important mais
c'est claude r imp à cape town investit
aussi dans les grandes entreprises où le
profit est primordiale et où le profit
est une condition pour pouvoir augmenter
petit à petit les l'impact sociétal
positif donc je voulais faire les deux
je ne voulais pas choisir entre mon
coeur et ma famille entre mon passé et
mon foot futur donc ils peuvent capte
voulais pas choisir entre les i de
l'impact et l'essai du capital ou
laisser du koweït et les demi finales
il y avait mes retourner cette tension
entre inpact first est fine first a pris
douze années des années que je me
demandez est-ce que je ne devais pas
choisir entre se chauffer ou finest
est-ce que je ne devais pas choisir
entre ma loyauté familiale et mes
ambitions personnelles
est ce que je pourrais rester comme
administrateur dans un groupe coté en
mousse et en même temps promouvoir
l'idée qu' il ya une autre manière
une autre façon d'investir
où le rendement financier est secondaire
est ce que je pourrais faire ça et cette
interview avec ce monsieur monsieur
patchouli qui est le président du giec
j'avais entendu une interview à la radio
où les journalistes lui posent et de la
question quelle était sa position sur le
débat entre économie bleue et économie
verte
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
d'économie veille c'est plutôt la main
levée il faut vraiment changer notre
mentalité
il faut éviter un conduit la voiture
utiliser les transports publics il faut
accepter un peu moins de luxe à un peu
moins de confort il les promoteurs de
l'économie plus c'est plutôt l'inversé
non les gens vont jamais changé leur
comportement
si les alternatives sont pas plus
attractifs au lieu de inventé une petite
voiture qui consomme que du litre
d'essence
c'est peut-être mu d'inventer une très
belle bolides comme tesla qui est 100%
électrique et qui roule aussi 200 à
l'heure donc la réponse de ce monsieur
pas jolie était le problème du climat
est si grand et si urgent qu'il faut les
deux il faut les verts et les bleus on a
besoin des gens qui nous avertissent
qu'il faudrait mieux changer notre
mentalité mais il faut aussi les gens
qui inventent des tesla donc cette
réponse pour moi était un vraiment
déclic aussi sur mon propre combat entre
fine first sochaux est peut-être il faut
les deux ce n'est pas vrai que les
investisseurs fine first ne sont
intéressés à l'argent et qui sont pas
être ici à l'impartition social non ils
veulent aussi maximiser l'impact
sociétal mais ils sont convaincus que la
meilleure manière des charges et le
monde
c'est plutôt de s'inscrire dans la
réalité dans la logique capitaliste
d'aujourd'hui et ce n'est pas vrai que
les investisseurs sochaux first ne sont
quatre essais à l'impact social social
et qu'il ne regarde pas les chiffres
n'ont eu aussi et sont dédiés à trouver
des solutions pour maximiser l'impact
social mais ils veulent surtout où il
croit que la meilleure manière de faire
changer le monde c'est prouvé qu'une
autre économie plus humaine est aussi
possible et durable et agréable donc
pour moi c'est les deux aussi inpact
first est fine first il faut pas mixer
les deux seb lui et vert il ya une
grande différence il nous faut pas une
économie turquoise il faut les deux il
ya les différences et c'est important
les différences sont pas un problème
c'est plutôt une solution une solution
s'il commence à collaborer son
désistement sakho crier au lieu de
discuter entre les du vision c'est
peut-être mieux qu'ils collaborent au
lieu de se rapprocher les uns aux autres
que eu sont des idéalistes naïve et nous
nous seul semblait réaliste ou linverse
que nous seuls
avons des intentions intègre et les
autres se sont que nous font que de
greenwashing
il faudrait me colle à louvoyer donc je
vais présenter deux exemples un exemple
théorique si un entrepreneur social à
trouver une solution qui peut changer le
monde qui est vraiment une solution
rentable
bush un problème sociétal il pouvait
faire deux choses ou bien il crie sa
propre entreprise sociale et essaye de
conquérir le monde avec ce produit
ou bien il pourrait aussi collaboré avec
une grande entreprise avec une échelle
plus grande avec un effet de levier
même si la grande entreprise ont fait
des profits donc co création
deuxième exemple des entreprises
françaises à paris il ya kino me et
danone qui nous met est une petite boîte
6 personnes et le but est vraiment de
planter et de préserver des amis parce
que il voit un grand problème en afrique
en amérique du sud sud est a dit avec la
déforestation déforestation donc le but
est de planter ou préserver des vins
donne le but est de gagner de vie est de
faire du profit mais la mission de
danone est aussi d'apporter la santé par
l'alimentation au plus grand nombre et
sont donc ces kilos mais qui a trouvé ou
qui a découvert un produit c'est à dire
la gomme arabique de cet arbre là c'est
la case raciale à chat pourrait
remplacer un ingrédient chimiques dans
les yaourts de danone
en plus c'est
meilleure ou la santé et en plus ça
pourrait être moins cher donc d'un an
est intéressé mais le problème il n'y a
pas assez de commandes arabique donc
l'idée était soutenue par des impacts
investor d'investir dans une manière
recruter cette gomme arabique une
manière professionnelle professionnels
cinq ans après il ya 3000 femmes qui
gagnent leur vie avec la récolte avec
cette collaboration avec danone il ya
quatre millions d'âmes sauver donc c'est
un exemple ou moi j'ai dit ok c'est ça
que je veux faire je vais promouvoir la
coopération
au début je me demandais quel type c'est
moi j'avais travaillé dans le magasin
comme vendeur et je dois avouer que
j'étais pas le meilleur vendeur donc
j'ai fait ça un commerçant
j'ai dessiné et construit les
supermarchés à bazas nagy mais je dois
avouer aussi que les calculs sont faits
j'avais pas fait les calculs des
ingénieurs et c'est la chute du mur
n'était pas très artistique donc il ne
reste que 1 type peut-être je suis un
traître philosophe impliquant un
promoteur qui s'est accumulée est compté
mais t'es vu surtout toucher et inspiré
messi